once again here on the show love it when
he calls in love it when he when he
joins his program because he brings to
this show what he brought to the draft
coverage last night he is Jay Bilas here
on the program how are you Jay I'm doing
great rich how are you I'm doing great I
fought the Sacramento Kings had the best
draft when I say that I'm not including
the Timberwolves because obviously
acquiring Jimmy Butler's a home run to
use another phrase what did you think of
the Kings draft last night Jay I thought
I thought overall the Kings did very
well I was a little bit surprised that
they took 10 and turned it into two
players but I wasn't you know I'm not
quite sure are as good as what they
could have had a 10th
I mean Zack Collins ultimately became
the pick for Portland if I remember
right and then in in Sacramento I had
Portland mate fixed to them of 15 and 20
so they got Justin Jackson of North
Carolina who's a good shooter and a guy
whose lengthy and to defend a little bit
and they got Harry Giles of Duke who you
know Giles has has been injured for the
last basically a year and a half and you
know so there's some risk involved there
I guess at 20 you could argue to get a
top 5 talent at 20 although injured and
you're not sure what's going to happen
you know it may work out in sacramento's
favor and that's as you said a huge home
run but for me I'm a little more
reluctant I would be a little more
reluctant to trade out of 10 because
Zack Collins is a is a potential star
and he could very well be one of the
five best players in the draft now who
knows whether he will be but but I tend
to think that you trade down from that
spot and you're taking more of a risk
for it than if you keep it so who do you
think was the best I guess this is the
phrase that we always use in the NFL
Draft value pick J I mean even if you
could even say folks because first
overall
you can't miss on it if he is the
can't-miss prospect that so many people
believe go for go go for that is your
option but who's the best value pick
from last night well
there were there were a few of them and
you know I agree with you like marquel
falses is great so you could call that a
value number one but a number one you
get whatever you want
when you pick further down at the draft
you sometimes take what falls to you and
sometimes you get lucky and I think
Phoenix got lucky they got now they
would have gotten a really good player
anyway but for them to get Josh Jackson
of Kansas to have to have him fall to
them because that he'd need the type of
player that you might want to trade up
to get and then another team that I
think got you know got a value pick
would be Dallas at number 9 to get
Dennis Smith jr. because he's a he would
be a top buy player in most other drafts
you know but they're valued players in
the draft that that are going to turn
out to be I think very good and there's
no way that 30 guys in this draft is
going to be really good players that
never happens but so you know you is
funny rich I mean you've been through
this more than I have but you know
before the draft I was on SportsCenter
and one of the questions the sports our
producer asked before I went on was okay
we want you to tell us like who you're
projecting to be kind of a draymond
Green type player out of this trap right
I was like look if I was projecting out
I'd rank him number one
I mean our you know what like it you
wouldn't you wouldn't be at the end of
the first round you know it'd be right
up top I don't I don't have that kind of
magic I I don't know I don't know who's
gonna be that guy I didn't think
draymond Green would be draymond Green
and I don't know who else did because he
got taken 35th overall yeah I mean while
we're crossing sports streams here J I
mean yesterday a derrick karr got 125
million dollar contract from the Oakland
Raiders and he was a second-round draft
pick if you read raft from his draft
he's the number one overall it can draft
you know you know that yeah that's a
really good point I think one of the
things you know right now the one and
done rule is being talked about a lot
rich in it I think it's kind of silly
because the one a done rule has nothing
to do with all this stuff and my
judgment I think it has more to do with
the rookie wage scale in the fact that
these players these young young kids
really are trying desperately to get
into the league to be pros because they
want to get
to their second contract they don't care
where they get drafted they want in to
start the clock so it's not like the old
days where they say you know they wanted
to be a high pick or all that stuff and
and the idea that the NBA needs more
time to look at these guys is wrong
because the NBA the NFL it doesn't
matter how much time they've had they
made the same mistakes when they had
plenty of time
and these one-and-done players do just
as well as you know they make to the
same decisions as whether they had four
years to look at them you know so this
is kind of I don't want to say it's
nonsense but if you want to keep them in
school so you could market them better
and it if they're a little bit more
mature when they get there emotionally
and physically and all that fine but the
idea of the business to make draft
decisions that rings hollow to me
completely Jay Bilas here in the Rich
Eisen show Marshall you were nodding
your head and agreement throughout that
entire yeah I'm so much is being said
about the the one-and-done rule and you
know I I don't know how it's hurting in
college basketball college coaches are
talking about that they don't like it
they wanted to go away but but I think
it shows the coaches that can coach
regardless of how long you have a player
you coach and I think you see that with
Coach Cal Coach K they're one and done
guys
they not only play well for them but but
they went on to play well and they na at
times they learned some of the values of
when you move ahead what's going to be
expected of you and both of those
coaches are now coaching their coaching
style definitely on offense is kind of
how they play in the NBA in a sense I
know Coach Cal he's only going to play
the way you will never see him play a
zone or anything like that
what do you think Jay well I agree
but I think that the coaches in college
lament the the one a gun rule because it
wears them out to have to replenish
their roster every year and so that you
know they've got to go they've got to be
constantly recruiting and selling and
it's not like it used to be for some of
the older guys where they could bring a
class in that they developed together it
is yet team chemistry you got to redo
everything every year and I think it
gets exhausting for them I don't think
anybody's feeling sorry for him with the
amount of money they're paying egg but
not that I was just about to say no to
you yeah that's what they're thinking
and and for fans you know it drives me
nuts when people say hey you know we
need the baseball world maybe they need
to go right out of high school or they
stay in college because the fans you
know they don't care about their
education they care in the abstract they
want to watch them and they want to
watch them for longer it's totally
selfish on the part of the fans which I
get but it's not like they're saying hey
we believe in education these kids ought
to stay in school that's not part of
this calculus at all they just want to
watch them longer and so why I'd love to
have them stay in school longer but I
want them to stay because it's in their
best interest not because like I'll be
fine I also watch look wants to play
basketball anytime Perl college like I
love the NBA LIVE college I love high
school I love all of it but but the idea
that you know hey we're like if we
really believe in education why would we
want the players to go out of high
school I mean you know that we'd
encourage them if you don't want to stay
according to our timetable the heck with
you you go off and be a pro that doesn't
make any sense to me and if we if we did
the baseball rule all all of the good
players in high school would go right
into the pros they would not they would
not go to college and play for free for
extra time they would all go right away
and the d-league is going to become a
better option going forward Jay when you
look at um the Boston Celtics obviously
they had the number one seed in the East
and then you look at their draft it
based on what they what they drafted and
the guys that they have coming back
I mean Kent Kent can they beat Cleveland
not as long as LeBron is there no that's
one of the things that it's a really
good question that's one of the things
that I was looking at what this draft is
you know for Boston to try to get a free
agent and to spend a bunch of assets
that way that might be better off a long
term having
I don't think they're going to be able
to be Cleveland x3 years if LeBron stays
there so I think you have to position
yourself to be at your best when LeBron
on the downside even LeBrons going to
get older I'm almost convinced with us
now but but you haven't showed it yet
but it but I would say you know he's got
to have free you know three more years
but if he leaves you know then all of a
sudden you know you don't need to to get
some crazy free agent because you're
right there already
in the east and I'll tell you this so
you didn't ask me about LeBron but it's
LeBron and this is just my judgment on
this and I have no idea what he's going
to do or what he's thinking but if
LeBron is thinking about going to LA to
play I don't get that one unless he's
just miserable his life is miserable in
Cleveland because I both stayed in going
anywhere and why would you go out there
and sort of risk losing in the
conference finals every year instead of
being in the East where you are going to
the final like LeBron is going to the
final and he can bring pieces to him and
and go after cleat and go out the gold
state he goes to the Lakers Lakers 131
games I mean they're not going to be
even with LeBron they're not
automatically going to be better than
gold state I don't get that one but but
maybe there's something that I have a
factor there on that Jay Bilas fresh off
the ESPN NBA draft said Susie asked bill
as the poll question and we'll update it
after we say goodbye to him go for it
which top five pick will become an NBA
all-star first Ron Zobel Jason Tate MD
Aaron Fox Josh Jackson or mark helpful
what do you think
I think Lonzo ball will because he's
going to get he's gonna have the ball in
his hands right away and I think the
Lakers are getting that up and down the
floor and from that from that platform
in Los Angeles I tend to think it'll
wind up being Lonzo ball although
marquel Fultz is I mean he's James
Harden is really really a remarkable
offensive talent but he's going into a
locker room full of young guys and and I
still think it's going to take
Philadelphia some time not that it's not
going to take LA some time but I think
it's good sake Philadelphia time to put
it all together
if Joe LMP can't stay healthy healthy
he's he's an all-time great player
potentially obviously if he's not
healthy then that sets us back a long
ways so if I if I may just take one
extra leap here Jay you by saying
Lonzo shows off that you recognize big
baller
when you see it because you are yourself
a big baller Jay Bilas so I'm basically
saying game is recognizing game here
well I mean I've got neither real does
recognize real as you know but I don't
uh I think I am looking forward to Lonzo
getting into the NBA and starting to
play so we could talk about you like I
can enjoy him as a player instead of
rolling my eyes when we talk about his
dad like I respect his dad very much and
he's done a great job raising I don't
know the other boys but Lonzo is a
really nice kid and he's respectful he's
a really good teammate and he's a great
player but I can't remember you know
sort of a player going into the pros
where there was so much time so much
talk about a parent and and it's been
such a distraction to enjoying how
talented the kid is and and I think this
will all go away
in pretty short order because I don't I
don't I don't see this being a major
issue going forward it's always an issue
in college and high school with the
recruiting stuff but boy I mean you know
I'm sure I would like lebar ball if I
sat down with them and hung out with
them but every time I see my television
all I want to do is change channel and I
want that feeling to go away because I
love it soft I think Jay bill is just
definitely brushed aside your big baller
coming yeah is that right Jake did you
just you just want you at serious answer
I know do you like to risk calling you
let the whole men calling each other big
ballers is kind of making me
uncomfortable it is a little
uncomfortable I'm an Under Armour guy
anyway so I'm not working look at you
Jay Bilas dropping dropping little red
crumbs right there Jay again a great
job love having you on this show always
so thanks for calling it appreciate it
Oh always my pleasure bye Fred thank you
you go to this Jay Bilas so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to